for more on the judge's ruling we turn
to Jesse Weber he's an attorney and
anchor on the law and crime Network
Jesse good morning good morning first
question for those people who have
coverage should they be worried right
now it's a concern it definitely is I
mean for right now the law stays in
effect nothing from a practical aspect
is going to change in their lives but
they're waking up this morning and right
before the enrollment in thinking what
does that mean for the future so anybody
that has a pre-existing condition
anybody that was relying on Medicare or
Medicaid or anybody that enrolled I
think up to 12 million people that's a
concern because that law that they were
relying on was just declared
unconstitutional but has to make its way
through the courts first was this a
surprise to everyone I mean was that tax
clause in that tax bill last year that
was inserted did anyone see this coming
I think they did and I'll tell you why
because and this is the argument from
the court right if you take away the
penalty if people are not don't have to
pay a fine for not getting health
insurance then what is an individual
mandate really it's unconstitutional if
you don't have that individual mandate
then what is the Affordable Care Act
because the Affordable Care Act was all
built on that penalty and that's what
the court said it said you really can't
have this and we're a court we can't
create a new law we can't say this is a
new regulatory scheme it would change
the whole landscape so you have this law
that doesn't have that penalty provision
there's no way this could stand now the
Supreme Court has upheld the Affordable
Care Act twice before if it gets back to
the Supreme Court the court looks a
little different now with Brett
Kavanaugh on the bench so how do you
think it'll play I'm so glad you
mentioned that yes we have a different
court it's a conservative majority
things if you are an anti Obamacare
person if this is your art or if you're
the architect of that this is the prime
time to get it repealed and replace the
thing is though and it's also decided on
a very different issue again if you
don't have that penalty provision if
you're not forcing people to buy it to
buy health insurance then this really
makes sense for it to be overturned now
the question is the everybody who's a
supporter of it they now have some
leeway they saw it with the judge
ordered to look at those arguments
they'll come back they'll make an
argument going forward it's not the end
of the story but this is not a
day for anybody that was rised so what's
the timetable here now Jessie because if
you've got the coverage you're wondering
how much longer might I have it for
right I would say everybody in 2019 is
probably okay yeah because the appeals
process takes some time yes they can try
to fast-track it through the appeals
court and then try to fast-track it
through the Supreme Court because it's
such a big issue but I've tried this
I've seen this to happen before I'd be
more concerned for people who are trying
to think about in the future what
they're gonna do yeah
and it's no guarantee that everybody in
2019 is is protected but I'm more
curious about 2020 especially with the
election a hundred and thirty million
people with pre-existing condition
that's a biggie and I've heard the
administration say look we're gonna try
to do something to protect these people
how congressional Republicans are like
we'll pass some sort of legislation to
protect them easier said than done
it's a problem at SC Weber we thank you
thank you